i'm very very reluctant to categorize
just about anyone as genuinely evil
because in my experience there are very
very few evil people
you know vladimir putin now that's evil
but uh you know just about anyone else
who's having an honest disagreement
uh i don't put in that category at all
and one of the symptoms of polarization
that we have is that people are willing
to cast their ideological enemies or
just someone who disagrees with them on
something as
uh
as evil and i think that's a disaster
uh like i you know i just myself very
much
not
um
not on that page uh and i i think that
we should try and get as many people
away from that page as we can do you
think that makes you a better or worse
politician
probably worse politician because uh
political figures like to cast things as
uh conflicts between good and evil and
it's like hey
you gotta
get us the resources we need to defeat
evil this one more time and if we do
this then all be well i mean i think
that's one reason why the
dissatisfaction
um among democrats right now is
pronounced is because it was framed as
defeat trump and then all of these are
incredible and then all these incredible
things will happen like one of the
things that boggles my mind when i hear
and i hear it all the time is when a
political figure talks about it's like
hey
if you elect me we will defeat racism
defeat sexism defeat and i'm saying okay
let me applaud that by the way we stand
up and get excited about that
let me get this straight if you're in
office then
no one then we won't be a racist society
or a sexist society anymore it's like
wow that's incredible i mean it's kind
of the the thing that that you know we
we're kind of excited about obama
doesn't mean we're not racist anymore
um so so when we continue to make those
appeals and then the reality does not
change
um then people get
uh kind of
you know fatigued
[Music]
this week on ford the batman the
greatest movie of all time zach grauman
joins the ranks of published authorhood
his new book long shot is available for
sale now
and what russia's invasion of ukraine
tells us
about america as a force for good in the
world this week on forward
[Music]
welcome back this week on forward we
have a bunch of
uh new developments that have come down
the pipe but first i want to come clean
and say that zac has seen batman and i
have not
and i'm rubbing it in man this movie
stop what you're doing stop listening
this podcast and go see batman i'm just
kidding do it after you listen is it
technically the batman
probably right
yeah you're probably right but it's
awesome
i can't wait to see it so i
kind of wanted to see it but then it
didn't work out so i'm seeing it at the
end of this week and i have to say it's
given me something to look forward to
because i'm like oh i'm going to go i
agree i haven't felt that type of energy
like i'm excited about this sadly like
in a while because when you feel it you
know when you're excited about something
did you see spiderman no way home yes i
was less excited about that but i was a
little bit excited so were you excited
coming out of that
yeah i left really happy yeah right
right right that's true yeah i left
happy with this one too though is that
movie overachieved like sort of knowing
home i was like oh my gosh i almost
can't believe i'm seeing this it was i
agree this was so here you go batman
y'all
uh the context i'll give you is my fa
i'm not a movie
buff per se but i like me i like to look
a little deeper than like the surface
level of movies uh christopher nolan if
i have to pick is my favorite director i
thought
uh going back to momento and uh
inception and some of his earlier stuff
the prestige like his stuff is awesome
and then what he did with the batman
series change superhero movies forever
and that's not
just my opinion many many folks i'm
gonna say something kind of tough sure i
feel like chris nolan's been on
something of a downward slope he's yes i
agree it is hard to keep that excellence
up you know because tenet
was not good confusing
i thought i was acted and shot well just
i didn't make and i also thought the
final batman movie was the weakest of
them uh with the one with bane dark
knight rises the thing that split
reviews on that the thing that made me
dislike that movie
was all of the police officers going
into the tunnels all which didn't make
any sense doesn't make any sense parts
of the logic didn't make sense they're
underground for approximately a week
and then they come up and they don't
have beards
like you know like like has has anyone
been showering down there apparently not
but like they're all just like it looks
like they've been down there for a few
hours i mean like what the hell do you
do down there for
all those cops to be a hot mess they
have guns and [ __ ] yeah that would be
awful or just like at a minimum you'd be
kind of you know and then they run down
i guess i was like i guess it's a
metaphor but it's like you know they're
like running toward the other anyway so
that that that was one of the things
that lost me i thought that
coming off the dark knight which is one
of which was great probably the best
maybe a movie
one of my favorite movies all the time
ignoring the genre um
tough and heath ledger passed away yeah
totally like which also added hype to
his amazing performance like go down the
list um to i thought he delivered like
when the expectations were so high you
can't beat it like i thought it was a
pretty good job all things considered um
and i did enjoy the movie a lot um but
i'll say this batman um some say like
knowing that how much i love the last
ones i was like all right
there are they gonna kill it like like
ruin it kill it um and then i thought
that the ben affleck batman's are pretty
awful
zack snyder right like no i mean he's
done some good stuff i love i love 300 i
loved uh
i actually liked the snyder cut of the
justice league i didn't like what they
came up with when the studio got their
hands on it anyway
that was awful
i was like what are they gonna do with
this and they got edward cullen
situation going on
uh with
our boy robert pattinson as batman and
it was
he might be my favorite batman honestly
first of all he's got the jawline for it
man like what a jawline on that dude
like i don't know if he's at work done
doesn't matter just freaking like you're
just you're looking at his jaw half the
movie and it's a good jaw
um
but he was
batman's always like supposed to be a
damaged character right parents died
grows up super rich lost in the world
right tries to use money for good but in
a dark way right but the christian bale
batman that was damaged was like
like my parents generation boomer
generation damage where it's like i got
pent up [ __ ] and i have to break stuff
to like get it out in unhealthy ways
this was very like brooding 21st century
damaged where bruce wayne is not this
cocky
philanthropist entrepreneur badass
business guy figurehead in the community
he's a damaged
rich prince if you will and
he's got the like he kind of looks like
edward cullen from twilight with like
the the hair swoop
um he's pale he's brooding and then it
made batman so much more interesting to
me um because it really felt a little
more relatable and then
the last thing i say it's shot to ave
maria essentially like it's shot to
classical and like it movie opens with
avi maria i'm not going to do spoilers
but that's like it opens with classical
music
and then every other fight scene is like
themed to that ave maria
throughout the whole movie it's
dynamite uh
matt reeves the director
kicked ass well done um
go see it man totally worth it totally
worth it there are a couple moments i
would you know we can nitpick and we i
don't want to spoil and stuff with that
but it was wonderful
yeah i can't wait yeah i will say having
it to look forward to has been a delight
next week i can share my
own experience uh which i'm sure it'll
be positive because this sounds right on
my alley truly just a random campaign
story before we move on sure you
remember seeing joker when we were
running for
president uh joaquin phoenix yeah
because yeah we were in new hampshire so
here's what happens you're campaigning
for president let's say yeah your last
event ends at 9 00 p.m
and then you're like what are we going
to do there's no campaigning at like you
know 10 p.m by the way your saturday
events aren't always early like
sometimes they are but they're not
you know it's usually it's a weekend
early it's like 10 30 or so so you could
stay up kind of late not super so we'd
be done at nine and then i would and the
funny thing about being a candidate too
is if i suggested that everyone's like
cool can't wait but like if i don't
suggest that everyone's like i guess we
should pretend to work or like that but
like what do you mean
between 9 00 p.m and midnight on like a
thursday or friday night yes we either
go to a bar or we do something right and
so i suggest it's like hey anyone want
to see joker and then people were like
yeah so do you remember seeing that yep
we saw movies all the time we saw some
bad ones and some good ones yeah so so
joker was a good one
and now i feel like the batman is kind
of a you know
complement to that to the extent you can
take any deep societal
uh lessons from the fact that this is
the new version of the batman any
thoughts you definitely can i think um i
don't want to spoil it but they the
riddler the the villain
is very much a version of this um
it's honestly guys like the damaged men
um on all sides of the coin here you
have it's a lot of what we're talking
about so i'm excited for you to see and
we can break it down but the
the villains themselves are you know
have their own issues with their own
masculinity uh the heroes for sure um
the the people that pick a side right um
it's really well done it sets it up for
success um the one thing i last thing
i'll say is uh
colin farrell is in this movie which i
did not i think i knew that like he was
apparently unrecognizable unrecognizable
because i forgot he was in it and didn't
i was like wonder who that actor was and
i was like that's colin farrell it's
wonderful i've been listening to
soundtrack all day it's a little creepy
to work to so don't really recommend
that um
anyway
i'm curious like dms if you hated it or
like i'm curious like most people i've
talked to have really liked it daily
mail said it was too like it that's not
true
if you don't like it
you have poor taste you suck no actually
i'm curious because i'm i'm curious of
our producers also love it so i sat next
to you i'm very very much expecting to
love it last thing i keep saying last
thing i'll say this was fun but i sat
next to a guy went to the movie by
himself i went with my sister because
carly
can't wait wait wait wait quick
digression
do you see movies by yourself
i try not to but i have i'm trying to
think of what last one i had i usually
if no one wants to go me out you just
wait i will say that i have 100 seen
movies by myself what was the last thing
you saw by yourself uh you know it's
been a little while but so this is one
situation that i've been in
um i
very much vividly remember this where uh
ellen and i have one
young child or baby or toddler uh the
baby goes to sleep at you know let's
call it like 9 30 p.m emily goes to
sleep with him and then i'm like what am
i gonna do
and then i think i could probably catch
a late movie
father of the year so i've definitely
done that uh
so there was a guy who saw it alone uh
so there was a guy so i went with my
sister because carly can't see these
movies they give her nightmares and she
just she cries during she cried at the
end of avengers
end game i think or infinity war one of
them like half the people you shouldn't
be yeah it shouldn't be i suppose that's
pretty yeah but most people are crying
at the end they're like whoa right
anyway but there's a guy who went by
himself and he's clearly like a huge
clearly like a huge fan and just like
giggling or like he's almost like
clapping the whole time and i like
normally i'd find that kind of annoying
because it's like a noise but i found it
really endearing that he like really
loved it and was clearly there for
he was super excited about it um
and he seemed to thoroughly enjoy it so
that gives me hope that the the true
fans really love it too
to the extent that i have seen movies
alone i think virtually all of them were
comic book movies or superhero movies
i would just be like what i in this way
show up and see the movie and yeah
that's the kind of movie i would go see
alone yeah criteria for that has to be
either like you got nothing else to do
just but now with like all the streaming
platforms less so the case um or the
movie you gotta see in theaters you know
yeah which is which has gotten weaker
and weaker for me i even see it saw dune
at home which i know i was not supposed
to do but i was like i saw it at home
soon
dude was definitely one of those
probably way better in theaters though
like the shots in that movie were pretty
wild okay so
see the batman
i can't wait to discuss this
2022 version
if you know me you know that i think
that our data should be ours
unfortunately every time we surf the web
there are big tech companies tracking
our every move our every click they want
to sell us in our data to the highest
bidder if that doesn't sound like
something you want and it shouldn't you
should use expressvpn like i do every
time you connect to expressvpn you get a
random ip address shared with lots of
other people that makes it just about
impossible for third parties to identify
you and your location and harvest your
data best of all expressvpn is super
easy to use no matter what device you're
on phone laptop tv all you have to do is
tap one button and you are there
anonymous
protected so if you really want to go
incognito and protect your privacy
secure yourself with the number one
rated vpn like i do visit
expressvpn.com yang and get three extra
months for free that's e x p r e s s vpn
dot com slash yang go to expressvpn.com
yang to learn more
[Music]
the second thing is i am holding in my
hot little hand what am i holding zach's
new book zach is said to be a published
author the name of the book is long shot
how political nobodies took andrew yang
that's me
national and the new playbook that let
us build a movement
it's real man i'm holding my hand the
advanced copy
we have the hard one dude it is now
on sale pre-sale on amazon so you can
look for it it's called long shot again
i'm gonna put it in my bio you've now
forced me to do a book launch which i
have not uh let's figure out this is the
pre-pre-law yeah
the thing that is now available and i
want to say to everyone uh this is the
book that you hoped i would write but
did not
and by that what i mean was
uh when you bought forward
uh if you bought ford there were stories
from the presidential
um but that was not the
backbone of the book uh if you will it
was uh in some ways uh a narrative
uh from the candidate's perspective but
it didn't go into the nuts and bolts the
stages
the decisions the drama
like it didn't read like a movie and
zach's book has all of that
[ __ ] in it it has all of like the
uh the what are we gonna do moments and
like the debate room strategy and yeah
stuff that you hoped that i would write
about and did not
zach wrote about but it was also a sign
of the different experiences we each had
where zack thought strategically and
tactically uh and in the
framework of a giant political campaign
and i did not because
my jam was wake up be like what am i
doing a local
radio talk show here in new hampshire by
the end too okay
and then where are we going next uh to a
diner okay
and so you know like i was uh
consumed with just trying to knock out
what was whatever
in was in front of me of course and so
then when i retraced my steps and wrote
the book like i i frankly did not
pretend that i was zack
but zach does not need to pretend
because zach is zach uh and so this this
book is
excellent uh evelyn is on the record as
saying she liked this book more than my
book
uh so i thought it's funnier like not
that i'm funny i'm not the story's funny
though like it's the the story is funny
the book is funny i guess that means by
definition you're funny i guess like i'm
a funny i'm a funnier writer than i am
like if you hang out with me and you're
not gonna be not funny
[Laughter]
you listen y'all this is podcast like
you know once in a while you know i bet
like 100 when it comes to jokes you know
most 90 of my jokes are not funny but
the book is funny the book is funny um i
got to edit it right um i got to cut out
and i had editors i literally people
paid to edit out my bad jokes um
so just good ones so the ratio is good
so look the point is like um and we'll
do a kind of a deeper dive on some of
the tactics in there because i think
like i get to interview zach it's gonna
be fun yeah yeah we're doing it but like
whether you agree
whether no matter where people come down
on you or me or your politics or our
policies or what we did there's
no doubt that we were on to something
and like i wanted to back up we
objectively over performed correct and
like what did we do that i thought other
campaigns should have been doing
and what does this say for the rest of
politics and branding in general because
we
frankly played a different game and so
the book is like what was that playbook
that let us play the different games and
i really would give you full credit zach
because you always had that different
game in mind
and you could see what other people were
doing in the conventional wisdom and you
were like that that's dumb and then you
would chart your own path in part
because you were new but in part because
you were confident had your own vision
uh and my quote on this book jacket is
my campaign would never have reached
millions without zac's leadership and
strategies anyone who wants to make
change in the world or who simply loves
an incredible story should read this
book andrew yang and i cop to that it is
excellent it truly is the book that you
hoped i would write but did not because
zach wrote it so it's gonna be fun
pre-order your copy right now long shot
uh we'll we'll continue to talk about it
we'll actually heck
uh zach will go through some of the big
lessons from it maybe i'll even do a
reading on one of the podcasts we'll do
an episode probably closer to launch so
it comes out in may but you can
pre-order it now i recommend if you're
gonna buy it buy it early so
because it's definitely gonna light the
world on fire and definitely getting the
new york times best seller list and i've
heard a lot of celebrities have said
it's the best book they've ever read but
that's just i've heard
i'm not sure many people say yeah many
people many people numerous people have
reported it's awesome but yeah pre-order
now my mother can be among the first to
read it and we can talk about it in
earnest so it's gonna be great um it's
fun i will say it is really weird
it's weird talking about myself you know
what i'm saying well one thing i don't
know how you do it
yeah
is uh that promoting a book you wrote is
difficult so i'm going to talk about the
different orders of difficulty of
promoting [ __ ] okay cool so
wait you're actually an expert in this
yeah because i've seen you swap useful
[ __ ] i've done
uh each of these i'm going to separate
it into
into five categories
and i'm and it's going to be from
easiest to hardest okay
okay so the hardest things to promote
are just you yourself
and uh the main example of that is
political candidacy it's very hard to be
like i'm running for mayor because uh or
president or city council or school or
awesome or whatever it is because it's
like oh like then what's your jam and
then you have to immediately follow up
with like and here's why i'm so awesome
impressive moral driven here's my cause
better than other people right like
you're asking people make a judgment
there and they have to make an objective
judgment on just how you are as a
performer yeah because people will do it
oh yeah you know what i mean this is
like what you're running for congress
all right let me hear your spiel and
then they're like oh this was you know
good or not good i'll say this we
churned through consultants and staffers
on the campaign not like we ended up
firing them but they'd come in the car
and you'd after a performance like you'd
get in the car and they'd be in there
they just start beating into you and
like nitpicking like don't smile like
that don't breathe like that say it this
way and i'm like you know we do seven of
these a day so imagine like you got the
guys who spent two hours a day in
aggregate getting [ __ ] on by you what an
awful experience stop like that like and
people couldn't help themselves it's
politics anyway well it's because that's
because that's the way they think
they're going to add value yeah you know
and it's i mean that's why they become
puppets it's a little bit like lawyering
because like lawyers you have to come in
the way you add value is by pointing out
like the you know the thing that could
blow up in your face so you get
intrinsically negative it's one reason
why i left the law as quickly as i did
yeah interesting um it's like the
consulting thing
that makes it the all right so number
one is you're the candidate that is the
hardest thing to promote because then
you have to just be like me i'm awesome
all the time but a not so distant second
is i am uh promoting a book that i wrote
because the book is very much identified
with you the reflection of you it's a
reflection of you there's no way that
you can say like hey i wrote this book
but i really don't care and it's not
that big of a deal because you clearly
spent hundreds of hours writing the book
and are a fine version of you too like
you had to take time to
that is a one-off thing you said it's
like
so i was an author before i was a
political candidate and it was deeply
uncomfortable promoting that first book
that i wrote smart people should build
things published in 2014 and going
around being like read this book it's
like really important or profound or
impactful
excruciating it's awful so i'm not
thrilled about this
book tour
if you will yeah like this promotion
yeah it's uncomfortable
so uh and you can lump into and by the
way boo hoo we wrote books it's hard
that's not what i'm saying we're just no
it's just it's just difficult
and so right right next to
book you could fill in any creative
project it would be the same art would
be similar right yeah like hey i wrote
the these these poems i guess it's close
to a book hey i made this indie film hey
i wrote a song hey this is my one man
broadway show yes hey this is
my music yes all of these
very painful to promote because you know
they're going to be making a judgment
and it is like uh you know a reflection
of you a reflection of you and there's a
moment where it seems like a little bit
self-indulgent for you to be trying to
get them to listen to your music of
course pay attention to me you feel
uncomfortable yeah so this is category
number two very very hard yep
category number three
is when
uh you're doing something on behalf of
someone else it gets easier yes you know
what i mean because it's like oh my
friend is doing this and so you sell
someone else that's easier than selling
yourself i am being a good friend by
promoting them and so you know please do
check it out and like this is me showing
that i'm connected and you know like
have friends or whatever and i'm a good
friend yeah i used to work with
financial advisors and they all they
could sell they manage money for people
and they have to sell themselves and
their best management skills every one
of them were better if they had someone
else selling their investment managers
yes so having a hype person wing person
or whatever yep very very important
number four
hey here's my company my brilliant
company idea project yeah so so this is
uh
doable because oh sorry this isn't this
is an order of difficulty yeah it's
order difficulty number one the hardest
is i'm the candidate number two is
here's my deep artistic offering from my
soul
and thus judge me song movie book yeah
play show whatever it is yeah okay
number three is i have this company idea
i want to pitch you on okay that's
number three number four is i have a
non-profit i i want you to donate to
that one's easy because you have
a
sense of morality you're a good person
and then and the number five is when
you're promoting someone else on someone
else's behalf okay that's the easiest
because then you're like hey i'm a good
person my friend is running for office
doing this thing and i'm trying to help
them out and they say no if they say no
because they don't like your friend
right it's not pretty much the further
from you the thing is you're promoting
the easier it is and also what the
people get back because you see more
selfless
but also what they get back are you
promoting a company right yes it's about
you but theoretically the company maybe
offers a service or something to try
or some sort of value prop right yeah
they'll be like a value exchange yes um
but the non-profit and the and your
friend those make you seem self-less yes
and so there's something selfish
about i'm running for office or this is
my artistic offering yes
now i'd argue you
if you want to leave a mark on the world
or make the world a little different
than it was like doing one of these five
activities is
in that you know possibly par for the
course right it's in the doing it's in
the category of what you need to do to
accomplish something right um well at a
minimum number five yes
or four
[Music]
we all struggle sometimes and it's
particularly true in the winter
sometimes you come back out of that funk
but sometimes you need some serious help
i mean professional help now getting
professional help is easier than ever
this podcast is sponsored by better help
online therapy and i for one am super
pumped to let people know about what
better help can do for you better help
is online therapy that offers video
phone and even live chat sessions with
your therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours give it a
try and see why over two million people
have used betterhelp online therapy this
podcast is sponsored by betterhelp and
forward listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com
yang that's b e t t e r h e l p dot com
slash yang
get yourself some better help today
you'll be glad you did
[Music]
um so i made a list of my life skills in
my twenties uh which i recommend highly
if you make illustrator high schools
have you done i did um
they shift a bit but i have
have you accomplished most of them no
i had a couple well what are they
i wanted to
oh my my life's goal is to
make a billion dollars and buy the
buffalo bills and keep them in buffalo
forever
and i've thought about that as like
facetiously but i'm like no i actually
want to do this and like i want it has
to be a legitimate
offer chance to buy the buffalo bills
because i imagine the pagulos who own
them they may i don't want my whole life
to be on a whim like he's like no i
don't want to sell them to you right but
like legitimately get at the table make
a real offer is there a chance the bills
leave buffalo always a chance small
market team all right always a chance
okay any bill's family yeah so what are
these other life skills of yours uh one
i mean that was one i wanted to some of
them i've hit right i wanted to get
involved in politics um did that pretty
well book proof book
yeah i was like i was like maybe right i
was like in the like maybe category um
the other ones are like family and
personal and things like that um yeah
get married have two kids yeah uh at
minimum
um though though two is fine um i'm
happy to say i'm knocked out like eighty
percent of my life's goals already
and i play house money yeah you know
they do morph to your point um so yeah
or like sometimes you think
you want to well one of my goals was to
start something right
so i did suddenly i started suit up so i
did that and that was great and i was
like okay
um then my other one goal is i want to
take a ridiculous risk because i look
back and like that's awesome who did
that with you um
um but then it was like you know one
goal is like i wanted to run for office
and like i still feel that sometimes but
you know that's not with a book tour bro
different calculation uh different
calculus now so sorry oh so some of my
goals are things like improve millions
of people's lives for the better have i
done that arguable arguably not yeah
have something good to write on your
tombstone so some of them are very very
big but the reason i raised this is that
one of my goals at the time when i wrote
this list was elevate a national
political figure that's right it was it
was not be one it was just like help one
end up being yourself um
and so this is your argument is that hey
in order to accomplish something you
need to tackle some of these promotional
elements and i would argue that
it's okay to be in number five which is
look i'm just going to help other people
who are doing great stuff yeah you don't
need to be the doer yourself you can
just be like hey i see someone who's
always doing something right let me help
them and so that's where i was when i
drafted this list in my 20s like i don't
need to be the guy
uh the the
problem that has occurred now
is that
uh
if you want to build certain types of
things like let's say a political
movement like you kind of need
a person to hang it on yeah and in this
case i was the person
uh and
now i still am right eight person
[Laughter]
yeah yeah um so so the the thing i would
suggest is number one write your life's
goals down they can be
uh small or big so one i had was you
know own a dog which we hadn't
unfortunately had to give away because
our older son was allergic um stay in
good physical condition which you know
is kind of come and gone
god come again running for office it
turns out ran very much
for physical health
physical health so some things are like
that there are other goals that were
very ambitious but writing down these
goals been incredibly
beneficial because when you have a
choice then you actually make the choice
that is in alignment with your goals and
if you haven't written your goals down
then you're not really going in a
direction yep it's a dream and then
choosing to elevate other people i think
is a fine way to go i do not think you
need to be
the person um if you find yourself as
the person then you know fantastic too
but like i wouldn't put that on people
so let me tell you this add-on so i used
to when i was at ubs
yeah i think i mean it's like corporate
machine of a for-profit bank right and
so and i'm in the philanthropy side of
things so there's all these millennials
coming to me
my peers younger a little older than me
come to me like
i'd love to do something that made me
feel good about what i'm doing or
something and uh what advice do you have
or how do i get into what you're doing
they weren't like wanting my job but
they want to know how to get like the
impact space or feel better about their
everyone wanted to work in that space
yeah it's a at least it's a base that
sounds good on paper for sure
um
but the best advice i could give people
is because i got it myself um
i'll say to you is someone said to me
stop asking yourself where do you want
to be in five years where do you see
yourself i hate that question where do
you see yourself in five years or what
are your life's goals exercise and those
are fine but the real question is
if you died today right now i just
pulled out a gun shot you're dead i
gotta deal with the consequences it
doesn't matter to you you're dead right
what would you be mad about not
accomplishing what would make you angry
and what's cool about the answer to that
question is that it's
essentially
you may hopefully you'll know instantly
but if not you'll know within 24 or 48
hours you'll know because you'll think
about it i'll eat at you and you'll know
and that
answer
doesn't you'll be surprised a lot of
folks it's not always career driven
actually most of the times it's not it
might be i wish i spent more time my
parents i wish i traveled to tuscany
generally it's going to be personal i
wish i became an expert in something
right
and then what you do so for me it was it
changes too over your course your life
so i said one was like oh i never
started anything maybe i should start
something right and then now i was like
frankly like my big one now is like now
i want to
frankly have more influence and frankly
like raise money like raise money for
good like use the money for good um or
build something that makes money for
good because i've learned the in the
power of that it's kind of where i'm at
i'm still kind of crystallizing it but
you'll learn that and what you'll find
is not always career driven
but it can drive your career because you
may learn i love wine
and now you need a job that lets you
maybe you want to be in san francisco or
you can go up to napa every once in a
while and learn or live in italy or you
want to spend more time with your
parents you wish your better father
husband xyz
now you set up the career to make sure
you're not living with regret um which
is what we're kind of all trying to
avoid we all want to maximize
the time we have so anyway best advice i
ever got um i didn't make it up
friend sarah waymeyer made it up or i
don't know if she made it up but she
told me about it i'll give her credit
she's a former colleague of mine she
probably doesn't listen to this but
i gotta give credit it's not me um
so a couple of very small things happen
there maybe i'm not that small but i i i
got a couple of
uh affirmations over the last week that
i want to share with people
um
so the first was that i wrote an op-end
for the washington post about struggle
of boys and men
uh i think most people here have read
that read it at least heard about us
it's not that long
yeah you should read it it's good um i
don't know i'll put the og version out
there by the way it was better
no offense to washington post because i
do like that they publish a lot of
op-eds
um that they did they added this bad boy
up they they edited it up yeah i mean
they have to it's like their job i'm not
saying uh so
uh
an english textbook
uh
company not any not british but like a
textbook uh you know it's like english
composition oh like english to subject
yeah okay subject
uh contacted
me
and wants to use that op-ed in their
textbook that would be taught in high
school english classes around the
country as an example of english
composition and like you know what i
guess sound argumentation
um so i'm super pumped about it because
it one it's you know kind of a nice
feeling but two the substance of that
article is actually going to be taught
in classrooms because if you read it
then you'll be like oh snap you know
apparently
like you know boys
uh struggle you know like it makes me
very happy yes sometimes you produce
things and you have no idea if it's
going to
reach an audience make an impact is it
just going to be
like a you know
like a pebble in a pond where their
ripples and the ripples disappear but on
this one i'm feeling pretty good because
hell if it's getting taunted thousands
of classrooms you know like it will
probably influence uh some people's
thinking it's a good legacy
theoretically yeah like it's kind of
high on my list of things more normal
people's being used as a as a textbook
in some a lot of college classes
gave me a similar feeling but this feels
even
uh wider in terms of scope because it's
like a lot of high school kids be
reading that yeah it's massively
important look let me ask you this
um
i think it's good advice won't talk
about starting things you said this to
me i wanted you to share with everybody
and elaborate on it you said every time
you start something
you're going to gain a bunch of friends
and you're going to lose a bunch of
friends if you do something significant
for sure yeah i mean if it's nothing
then you won't care but yeah um
and you said that to me and i was like
absolutely because you have a bunch of
people that say you're they're your
friend but then when push comes to show
you're like hey will you donate to this
cause or you come to my launch event or
will you
send this to your friend like introduce
me to your friend that works at xyz you
got like little things you'll ask your
good friends to help you with something
you'll be surprised who does it who
doesn't
you'll be extremely surprised yup um
what's happened to me over mind blowing
surprise actually and it's it's even
more surprising though the folks that
actually do help um because it's usually
not you not who you expect well you you
form relationships out of it like
someone will drop everything to help you
and then all of a sudden you're like i
love you you are great thank you yeah
i meet great people through the forward
party every single day and i appreciate
the heck out of it it's true of the yang
yang tune the presidential
always lobby three learning i'm still
meeting new people actually meeting a
ton of people the lobby three people are
really that's going great awesome by the
way it's going fun we're excited to make
that happen um yeah so that was one
really positive piece of news it was uh
small but it felt great the other thing
that i guess objectively would be
considered significant is i was asked to
speak at the commencement of uh columbia
law school which i'm a graduate of yeah
and so you can imagine being asked to
speak at the commencement of your alma
mater it's like it's a big deal man how
you feeling i haven't congratulated you
personally congrats yeah i i got that
and i was like wow really well
what happened like they just said dear
andrew
of colombia
a friend who's a professor there texted
me being like hey uh great great news
they want you to speak you'll get an
official thing but let me know whether
you'd be positively inclined before they
they send it drum up yeah so apparently
you know they want to be they don't want
to be turned down i guess and so
so i looked at the date and was like i
can do that and then so then they sent
me a nice letter
are you uh
i'm assuming you're going to write a
speech and not weighing it yeah i'm
going to write i've actually started to
think a bit about what i'm going to say
i wanted to be relevant to people who
are at that age and stage
which i i do remember
but yeah you know i mean a commencement
speech is its own
form you know what i mean i don't know
what my ambitions are my ambitions are
just to do a good job for the people who
are right there um but i will probably
write something and share it because
yeah you know i mean why would i do the
work just for a few hundred people if
you can
well very rarely do you get to i mean
you're different running for president
but very rarely in life do you give get
to give a speech
where hundreds or thousands of people
like are actively listening and you can
even argue parts of politics not
everybody's actively listening but i
would say in a couple moments weddings
and graduation speeches people are
listening they're like hoping someone
gives a good speech
when you go if you're been to a college
graduation you're like oh this doesn't
suck like it's hot maybe look for
someone distract you i will say that was
on my one of my goals like give a
commencement speech and when i was a
senior
graduating from college they had a
student commencement speaker option
and i was like [ __ ] yes i'm gonna do
this one because i didn't want it was
for my major so public policy was like
we probably had 400 you got chosen i got
well no one a few people applied but it
wasn't like as competitive as i thought
it was um so i got chosen i gave the
speech and i didn't tell my parents and
surprise them which was hilarious
because it's funny proud moment i think
for them but um but honestly like no one
wanted it because everybody was hungover
um
graduation day or whatever did you um
did you move mountains with it i moved
mountains uh i thought it was a good
speech uh yeah that was good i thought
it was good i'm probably probably
somewhere on youtube um
but
i will say
that's pressure fueled by the way um
similar to nuts yeah it's up there with
the best man speech in the sense that
everybody knows you're giving the speech
the most the most nervous i've ever been
was for my best my brother that's
terrifying
because you know you only got one shot
at it one shot everybody's remembering
it and if it goes poorly you never get
it back i feel like we talk we said talk
about this far sets a tone for the whole
wedding there have been so few speeches
i've had to give where i was like i'm
not going to get this wood back
yeah you don't get married again
it's like well i give a speech i can do
it better tomorrow right yeah i'll just
do it better tomorrow but then uh for
that one it was like well my brother
hopefully just gets married once more
nervous before the best man speech or
the democratic debate stage first time
maybe the second time because the first
time you were really sick yeah did i
talk about the book actually best man's
speech really yeah i was really i was
like uh i i was so nervous that
i you know was
quarreling with evelyn because you know
we're running late or whatever i was
like i really cannot be late like
the rest of it um so
yeah i was very very nervous
uh i was a little bit nervous i also
married uh my cousin to her
husband yeah this was when i was running
for president and i was totally
unprepared i was like and i was like
it'll be fine and then i got up there
and then i actually did get nervous i
was like no you told me you did a good
job though you did it went well oh yeah
you know okay they're still married to
this day yeah i did it
because the other thing about if you
ever best man um
everybody knows your best man so they
ask you about your speech the whole time
before it happens so if you're
if you're just 10x your nerves just
because of that fact alone like if
you're kind of nervous the fact that was
like are you ready for speech you're
ready for speech are you nervous you
feel like you're carrying the weight of
the wedding on your shoulder which is
really weird cause you shouldn't be it's
not your wedding anyway i did feel that
i felt it's in again don't [ __ ] up and
they're still married so you know i'm
like doing great i'm still married yep
brother's still married my cousin's
still married uh so
so those are some of the positive things
that have been coming around uh where it
feels like there's some energy lifting
the
message and ideas we're putting out
there
[Music]
so the big subject
we wanted to talk about this week was
born of of course russia's invasion of
ukraine which is horrendous and tragic
there were some comments that we were
too glib about it
um because we have casual conversations
i won't be very clear
the situation's [ __ ] up it's dark it
breaks my heart
i'm not okay with this it's not casual
to talk about world war three
you and i have a tendency to
try to see the positive things in life
and laugh um it's how we cope i'm sorry
if people are offended by that i mean
that's the type of thing i'm i don't
like to apologize too often for internet
comments but that's a real one to me
sorry
i mean i i agree yeah i mean it like
every day you wake up and you uh zoom in
and you see the
the death and the strife and the
refugees heartbreaking it's awful so to
that point
so as someone who whose family
immigrated this country the the sense of
america as being
a good place i mean there's this idea of
american exceptionalism where everyone's
like america has a special place in the
world and i think uh you know
uh shining city on a hill standing on a
hill yeah was that
reagan that was reagan yeah so so uh
shining city on a hill
uh and then in in during reagan you had
the berlin wall come down you had the
ussr
uh lose the cold war right and so there
was this arc of america as this
uh force for good and developing
democracy there was this idea wow was
this incredibly positive but they called
a period like the end of history because
they said at this point democracy
and uh globalized economy were going to
win and then that was that what a what a
happy positive moment that was
uh now things have kind of
rebounded
um because
um you've had authoritarian countries
come up and demonstrate that there are
different models of
competitiveness and success most
prominently china there was like a long
period of time when america thought hey
if we can just get
commerce in there then they're going to
liberalize they're going to wind up
democratizing because you can't have
this thriving chinese middle class
buying washing machines and watching
western movies who are
going to accept a repressive regime of
course that was all wrong like that it
turns out that they're perfectly happy
with
um not perfectly happy i mean i don't
mean to say that but that that like you
know there hasn't been like a real
contest
of um
ideas within china in terms of democracy
versus uh authoritarianism
so the the there was an arc throughout
the 80s certainly under reagan and bush
and then i would i would argue it
persisted through the 90s that america
was this
exceptional democracy uh and then
there's been this increased questioning
of that there's been like an increased
questioning of conventional histories
um saying that uh you know like and
again america
does have massive moral stains
uh on its uh on itself um throughout its
history but i
i still
feel like this should be a time for a
re-inspection
of both america's place in the world and
whether one would accept that america
despite its failings is a force for
improving people's lives
uh
everywhere around the world hopefully um
and also that there are massive
opportunities for us to improve people's
lives here and now
you know within our borders uh
that there's like a positivity you know
it's like that this sense if you lose
the faith that america will do the right
thing then you lose something very very
enormous and one of the things that i
try to do
um and and people you know sometimes you
know said like oh that this approach
won't work or whatnot but i think you'll
appreciate this having started a
non-profit
is you
you believe
that someone's going to help and then
you kind of present that belief to them
and then sometimes they help
yeah you know what i mean yep like i i
feel that about america where it's like
you believe america will help whether
it's
help the the ukrainian people
uh end this war and and
convince putin that this war was deeply
profane and unjust um or whether it's
helping americans live a better life
where you say look uh you know there is
no reason why we need to have
this level of scarcity and deprivation
and poverty in the richest country in
the history of the world like we can
actually
make those changes
uh so the this is something that um
i i believe in my heart first that this
is a good country and that the people
are good um but i also think it's a
better way to go because it's more
likely to lead to what you want
it's more likely to lead to good places
right let me see this real quick come on
i'm gonna do what you've done to me a
number of times i'm gonna quote myself
and this is actually real medic because
i'm gonna quote
look at this he's quoting a book that
has not yet been published by that you
can buy you can buy right now i'm gonna
quote myself quoting
someone else when you're young you think
the cavalry is coming to save us
when you grow up you realize that you
are the cavalry
quote andrew yang i don't know where you
got that quote from but you're my source
on this
and it's kind of what you're saying it's
like
america
by like or is the bill clinton quote you
said there's nothing
wrong with america that can't be fixed
about with what's right about america
yeah there's nothing wrong with america
that can't be fixed with what's right
about america and theoretically america
is set up to bring the cavalry
that is what it's set up to do
it like appeared like close you know
massive democracy
[Music]
the question i have for you is if if
america
doesn't exist right now
in the form it's in in its superpower
form
who stops putin
maybe the eu and that's a big maybe like
maybe nato right that's not the eu but
well you got to know that the u.s is the
muscle of nato yeah so
nato less
or us less nato
like
he probably does what he wants and
that's the point like if we don't exist
the the other major domino that
everyone's talking about is china
invading taiwan
yeah because there are a lot of
parallels of course and i obviously have
deep ties to the region
as the debate moderators would say
because they always just ask me china
questions um
jesus well to the region i mean
i have family in china too
so uh but everyone knows that uh
what's happening in ukraine will and the
u.s response
um will be something of an indicator of
the response to
uh
an act of aggression on the part of
china against taiwan to reintegrate
because historically
so russia's making the case hey ukraine
is part of russia the ussr like we go
back a long way it turns out ukrainians
do not want to be part of some
reconstituted ussr
now
the parallels with china and taiwan
uh they were
one country
uh until the late 1940s
uh and then they the nationals came over
um and so they've been distinct from
each other for you know it's called
seventy uh
three years or whatever it is um but if
china has a very long you know
frame of reference so they'll be like
hey we're one country
uh and so that's been their attitude
from
you know day one
um so for them to
try and take back taiwan is just
reclaiming
uh something that has always been
part of you
which is i believe kind of the russian
thinking which obviously that that's
completely uh off base
um so
your your question about an american
vacuum of power and what happens i mean
it's it's something people are asking
around the world yeah
because like it or not there really is
no heavy weight
and no one likes to think this is the
problem no one likes to think like this
we're talking about necessary evils no
one likes to think that you know like if
we're
if you don't think america is good
but we're a necessary evil because that
evil's worse right um maybe that's what
it is you know like america's done a
bunch of terrible things to get to where
it is right done a bunch of amazing
things too right
um
capitalism
causes a whole bunch it helped us build
the greatest military in the world right
and the most powerful um
put resources to work very very quickly
it's also had a bunch of people pile up
at the bottom it's been
unjust in many ways right this is these
are the these are questions no one knows
the answer to right but i i think your
point which is a good one is that
as we
look at this war it's a
powerful and good reminder of what
actual evil looks like yes
you know and and that framing
troubled
institutions like a country with
problems like america as evil in the
same way is not right it's not the same
no and it should things like this should
unite us um
i don't know if the media is set up
anymore to
to get to us to get us to a national
consensus cash relief and ubi is
actually the closest thing i've seen to
a national consensus on anything in a
while and that we all want to help
ukraine uh and the ukrainian people yeah
you know i feel like that's this is the
biggest one we've seen yeah that's as
close to uh rallying cry as we've seen
um
so
we're gonna unpack this
in a future episode um
in ways in terms of this let's call it
relative evil which sounds strange but
it's real it's relative morality in a
way
um applied morality well you know what
it is zach it's like it's framing
something troubled as evil
when when troubled might be a better
descriptor you know i mean yeah it's uh
you know it's like i told a lie
but i'm not a liar right like it's what
like i mean if you do it all the time
then you're an actual liar but if you
make a mistake i don't think you're a
liar right you're in person yeah
now there's certain things that don't
you know shot somebody like i thought
that's one of the things that people
sense about like the forward party and
me and the rest of it is like i'm very
very reluctant to categorize just about
anyone as genuinely evil
um because in my experience there are
very very few evil people
uh you know vladimir putin now that's
evil
but uh you know just about anyone else
who's having an honest disagreement
uh i don't put in that category at all
and one of the symptoms of polarization
that we have is that people are willing
to cast their ideological enemies or
just someone who disagrees with them on
something as
uh
as evil and i think that's a disaster
uh like i you know i just myself very
much
not
um
not on that page uh and i i think that
we should try and get as many people
away from that page as we can do you
think that makes you a better or worse
politician
probably a worse politician because a
political figures like to cast things as
uh conflicts between good and evil and
it's like hey
you gotta
get us the resources we need to defeat
evil this one more time and if we do
this then all be well i mean i think
that's one reason why the
dissatisfaction
um among democrats uh right now is
pronounced is because it was framed as
defeat trump and then all of these are
incredible and then all these incredible
things will happen like one of the
things that boggles my mind when i hear
and i hear it all the time is when a
political figure talks about it's like
hey
if you elect me we will defeat racism
defeat sexism defeat and i'm saying okay
let me applaud that by the way we stand
up and get excited about that let me get
this straight if you're in office then
no one then we won't be a racist society
or a sexist society anymore it's like
wow that's incredible i mean it's kind
of the the thing that that you know we
we're kind of excited about obama
doesn't mean we're not racist anymore
um so so when we continue to make those
appeals and then the reality does not
change
um then people get
uh kind of
you know fatigued disheartened like you
can't motivate people
with
fear
and hatred um all of the time
and then not have it either exhaust
people
or
distort them that's the
it's the difference between a good
politician and a good operator so i love
this so medicare for all right if you're
a good politician you're gonna have a
stance on medicare for all like keep it
as is or we're going medicare for all
and that's it free health care for
whatever it is right
if you're a good operator
and you want to get something done
you're like okay right now we have
medicare for nobody you know in this
hypothetical in you know situation would
i take medicare for 80 percent over what
uh my current situation yes would a good
operator take 60 to 70
yes
but we don't because it's good versus
evil right if you're not medicare for
all if you're medicare for 99 you're
evil you're out and we've lost our
ability to negotiate i actually talked
about in the book it's like that's your
brand is so identified with
a strong issue you can't compromise
it's bad politics to compromise you have
all the incentives to go the other way
so to sum up america
has its problems but it's no [ __ ]
russia
we shouldn't laugh about that
but i am because
it's like the rats you know i sometimes
think we should call this podcast the
rational progressive like i consider
myself extremely progressive
in the sense that i want to
make the country better you want to help
people and you know but i want to do it
in a way that's going to work and like
i'd rather
get called after being an [ __ ] i'd
rather be everyone think i'm an [ __ ]
but solve the problems yeah i mean this
is the the increasing problem yeah my
friend is that uh we're arguing arguing
um meanwhile our institutional
performance keeps getting worse and
worse and like people's lives getting
worse and worse and like the arguments
just get more and more heated and
you know uh
you and i just wanna actually
uh make things work better and solve the
problems well you could call that
rational progressive you could call that
pragmatic you could call that a life
there are more people that think like us
like this
than there are that you see in the news
that are extremists it's about i think
that
and you know this because you live this
with the forward party but yeah i do we
have to bring together the rational
middle if we can
and the rational middle i'm going to go
on a limb thinks that america is a good
place a good people
a good country and for my money they are
right amen
amen preach on brother
all right we'll be back next week we got
john wood on monday
from braver angels yes
and you and i back thursday
books out
check it out long shot long shot you can
google longshot by zach or you can it'll
be on my twitter bio
check it out
uh get this book we're going to do a
reading next week you can you know no
we're not going to read it so we're
going to do spoken word that's actually
one of my constant jokes is that like i
would just bust out my book and be like
and now i'm going to write
and now chapter two
i did read the audiobook that's an
adventure too we'll talk about that and
yeah
it's gonna be zach's author coming up so
yeah you guys definitely need to get a
copy reading rainbow was my favorite
show growing up man that's uh
you know i'm with you picking up it down
[Music]
you